today for the first time we got solid
information on whether the lockdown is
working in england
and the answer is sort of the big office
for national statistics survey
says that 1 in 80 people had the virus
in england between 7th and 14th november
that's a bit up from last week when it
was 1 in 85.
now and this graph of infection rate
since may shows you what that means in
context
you can see right over here the virus is
flattening off
but it's doing so at a high level
when the first lockdown was lifted in
june one in
1700 people had device all the way down
here
we've got to get from there to there
and we've only got two weeks of lockdown
left to do it
it's worth bearing that high infection
rate in mind when we look at the r
number
which today was lowered to between 1 and
1.1
it's good news that it's lower but when
infections are high it needs to be quite
a lot
lower than that to bring them down
lowering r
it's a bit like taking your foot off the
accelerator it has much more of an
effect
if you're going at five miles an hour
and if you're going 105
of course it's not just the number of
infections that matter but who's getting
infected and here there's some good news
this chart shows infection rates for
adults by age
and you can see over here this dark blue
line infection rates are dropping
among the over 70s that's a relief on a
basic human level
but it also means hospital emissions
will probably drop as well
reducing the pressure on the nhs
but with covert there's always a but
these lines
represent infection rates among younger
people and you can see they're high
and even growing this gold line is 12 to
16 year olds
with numbers like this national
infection rates are unlikely to fall
very quickly
and while these lines are going up
there's always a risk that young people
might mix with older people and that
could potentially
be dangerous so overall some good news
but with lots of opportunities for
mixing coming up we are not out of the
woods yet
not by any means